my name's Samuel leagues I'm the  best-selling author of the book by  low-rent hi and today I've got a massive  free gift for you  now I do training courses up and down  the country and one of the things that  I've seen are there are property  investors support forums and they  usually cost to be part of a forum a  mastermind group online they usually  cost a couple of thousand pounds per  year to be a member or I have what I  believe to be the richest rorish and  realist property investors forum and  it's on Facebook and I am giving people  right now free access to that group  where you can have all your questions  answered about property investing and  really be part of a family that support  you cheer you on in your goals I hang  out on there quite a bit  pointing to do is click the link below  and I look forward to accepting your  request to be a member  absolutely free